previously on TV sentence tear sweetness
inner smile bright light shines from our
eyes listen if you start off the show
with a bombastic view of the title city
even if you don't actually say it best
believe we're gonna roll some bat
marshals on your ass roof running
superhero posing sprinting feet for
another useless superhero pose ran do
standing up excitement where the [ __ ]
did this kid come from the roof dive
okay maybe she managed to parkour Plinko
down the building but she sure she
didn't fly across the road to land on
the food truck from this angle Kitty kid
can fly off rooftops and has a sixth
sense for milk and grocery bags this
character is Opie already we barely
crossed the minute mark also buys two
half gallons of milk when they can just
buy a gallon for less she just pulled
off the Keyser söze of dairy deception
to grab her lovely lactose but couldn't
swipe this guy's wallet without getting
caught the very idea that Kitty kids
stopped on a rooftop to chug this jug
makes me feel disgusting inside stay
calm Bruce god forbid that we get even
two minutes into a Batman related
property without seeing Tom and Martha
gunned down Joe could have had this plot
point show up in a news headline and not
one person would have given a flying
Batarang the slain Wayne trope is like
the electoral college I get that it
served a purpose a long time ago but it
might be time for a different take also
what's up with these pearls and we see
her take them off they are clearly all
the same size but once they hit the
streets some of them have shrunk I've
always wanted the story we're all of
Batman's rogues gallery tracked this
[ __ ] down and tortured him for five
issues because he created Batman bat
helm screamed in a scenario where all
these police officers opened fire
wouldn't everyone in the cells be
concerned with their lives instead of
having a front-row seat my pills
this works we have our hero you can tell
by how suavely he catches the bullet I'm
calling it the real villain is whoever
has the monopoly on yellow tinted light
bulbs in Gotham oh the legendary Harvey
ball with whether or not Harvey Bullock
would have been Jim's partner before he
became Commissioner is debatable as is
when he even first appeared some say it
was 1983 with Batman 361 and some say in
1974 is Detective Comics number 441
which is crazy because we all know Tim
Burton didn't invent Batman until 1989
that's Thomas and Martha Wayne I need
that kind of hassle call Major Crimes
they'd love to have this yeah but
they're not here and your partner is
talking to the witness I'm not sure how
that prevents anyone from calling major
crimes also I'm pretty sure they're too
busy sucking as a spin-off to the closer
Jim our hero is about to provide comfort
to this grieving child just witnessed
his parents death when I was about your
age
drunk driver hit our car filled my dad I
know how you feel right now way to make
this all about you Jim dick George
Gordon Alfred Pennyworth this is
literally the third time in the last
three minutes that Jim Gordon has said
his full name
this shows first 10 minutes have
basically been remember those awesome
characters you love from the Batman
stories here's our younger version of
them saying their own names so you know
it's them the TV shot what exactly is
the light source of the Titan sighs beam
panning in the windows and scorching my
retinas this restaurant owner chose a
terrible place to build anything with
windows don't start talking about I'm
still not sure I'm following this hole
if you talk to the witness the case is
yours line I think Jim couldn't give his
statement he got from Bruce to some
other detectives if the case got passed
on grizzled cop doesn't want to be
paired with a new cop because he's too
old for this cliche she said you were a
war hero and your daddy was a big shot
da back in the olden days did she though
because we saw that entire conversation
and I read the subtitles she says teach
him the ropes and yes the rest of the
conversation is just you yelling at her
so when exactly did she have time to
express these very cogent thoughts to
you no one will be seated during the
harvey interrogate random stereotypical
ruffian types with a hanging light
swinging back and forth montage just
tell me Ed I want riddles I'll read the
funny pages now we're showing earlier
Riddler kaathal these criminals are
already around bruises this young then
we're being forced to watch a show about
the worst police force in the history of
television and if that's the case then
what are we even doing here guess what
this is inadmissible and improperly
documented evidence that never passed
through the incredibly important train
of custody
Gotham seems like a horrible place to be
and yet I want to live there immediately
fireworks how this professional know the
Wayne's would be coming down that out
Jim thinks the Wayne's have been killed
by a professional contract killer and
this is the question that causes him to
reconsider I am no killer but if I were
I'd have plans within plans and just go
with the one that presented itself like
for example your targets walking into a
dark alley
why didn't we come to our first it's
kind of a last resort over the rain and
Gotham it was said that some could hear
the tears of the five remaining Papa
Roach fans then where's my money
the original name for this character was
over enunciate Mooney boy sorry if you
let this hair go frizzy you will be uh
wasn't she getting rained on the whole
time she was bitch-slapping her employee
Jim needs to go down the stairs to the
ground level to see the beating in the
street but they should already be on the
ground level based on how they entered
fish's hang up take it easy penguin I
don't like to call that man how about
Joker Mad Hatter Clayface the
ventriloquist man bat Red Hood owl man
Harley Quinn and Deathstroke or kite man
sorry I thought we were seeing how many
Batman villains we could name in
50-minute episode these ladies have been
on this stage sexually stretching since
Harvey and Jim are on maybe just take a
seat in those chairs and wait unless of
course they're just another piece of set
dressing the show is using to show us
how dark and gritty it can be you ready
Mac no Barbara I'm beat and do we really
have to go to this thing now considering
you had a full roaring fire in the
fireplace my pecet Department was
already planning on you staying made a
promise to Bruce Wayne and I can't
deliver yes the show is still using
characters full names for effect and yes
I will submit every time it happens
Gordon would most certainly just say I
made their kid a promise but Gotham's
got a Gotham I guess fish Mooney heard
from one of her fences guy tried to sell
him an antique four-strand pearl
necklace with gold settings one strand
broken great detective work detective
except her necklace was a three strand
pearl necklace so hi mr. nan hi V this
rooftop chase is the same rooftop chase
and every cop show ever in the history
of cop shows it even pulls the full
cliche bingo of an escape through the
window cliche the police yelling stop
stop rush a cliche chasing someone down
the fire escape so we can get different
perspectives cliche and the classic
chased through a restaurant kitchen so
we can get loud noise stuff flying and a
knife as
weapon cliche seriously the scene should
have totally cleaned up at the 2015
Vanity Fair cliche Awards hey Harold I
think the audience gets that this is
gonna be Catwoman maybe not maybe we
could have her liqueur ass damn Harold
she's 15 you sick [ __ ] just have a
remover hood with a cat paw motion for
[ __ ] sake huh lick their ass I didn't
shut up Harold you kept your promise
thank you sorry you didn't see a trial
what I had my palms read once and was
told that when the middle finger and
ring finger are the same in length like
this that it meant masculine greatness
this is interesting for two reasons one
Bruce here is going to become Batman and
two my middle finger and ring finger
aren't the same like does he know you
like I know sure why not add another
confusing soap opera esque plot to the
mix I could never be too many know as my
husband had his demons but he never
killed nobody are you sure because he
was very much trying to kill Gordon on
the rooftop shiny shoes mother of God
first of all I totally agree with ken
narlow here that this whole shoe
exoneration is a bit of a stretch but
mostly I just wanted to say that shiny
shoes mother of God may be my new
favorite phrase to use when I'm
frustrated shiny shoes mother of God are
people still setting off fireworks we
kill them we lose our jobs at the very
least Harvey the same man who said
somebody takes a cop's gun you shoot him
that's basic he is now concerned that
he'll get fired for literally saving Jim
from being murdered by a suspect is this
guy drunk or something paid for 57 in
the TV drop handbook states when wanting
your character to seem super-smart
always show them winning at poker unless
they are a criminal then use chess at
least Gotham's going by the handbook
Sheen you ask Harvey he's your partner
I'm afraid in my line but Gordon thinks
fish will tell him the truth the most
unbelievable thing about this series
might be that Jim wasn't shot dead
before the pilot and wait I want to die
how my father died peacefully in his
sleep
not like his screaming terrified
passengers for the love of Jackie legend
Dick's Wilson please tell me this isn't
supposed to be the Joker you snitched to
the MCU the DC EU has no shame
do you a second ago please let me live
I'll do whatever you say I'll be your
slave for life slave for life just
happened to be the name of the one-act
play I wrote in college about my
infatuation with frosted flakes and
Britney Spears also in another crime
show that didn't have all the Batman
baggage this would be a really intense
scene and maybe this would even be a
really good show but since we know he's
not going to kill this guy because he's
the penguin the scene holds zero tension
[Music]
the thing is stayed all the way back at
the car so you couldn't see all the
obvious fake assassination is obvious
that was going on we killed Madison man
who was about to stab you man he held
his breath for a really long time to see
an actual penguin in this version no one
can resist my Schweddy Balls
Jim you seem like a nice guy but this is
not a city or a job for nice guys get
the message now yeah are you sure you're
a cynic slovenly lackadaisical cynic you
can slice him you can dice him but the
Quinn man just keep danke hey Oswald
wanna turn ya know swing way pave as my
own thing all day all day all who's the
friend detective James Gordon ma'am
hmm we don't see if he's still got some
magic in that Mike from you data you are
fully functional aren't you of course
but Oh fully in every way of course I am
programmed in multiple techniques a
broad variety of pleasuring ah new cure
that's exactly what I hoped but Mario
pepper We Need to Talk
if you need Mario
coming Bennett
too sexy for my shirt 64 my shirt
she wants to kill policeman you have to
ask me nicely look at Jim almost me look
at me look at me okay technically I
shouldn't be getting laid but I do and
do you know why Dave there is a
mysterious ritual that dates back
thousands of years no living creature
has survived it except the penguin